not until lieutenant ahora yeah
do we even appear in the future right
you know now gene roddenberry didn't
realize how big a deal this was cuz he
didn't he didn't realize that we didn't
appear any the social impact of it again
he just doing it cuz it seems like the
right because it's the right thing that
does so when levar comes to my house I
said what do you do this is yeah I'm
getting ready to start I was like dude I
want in I want to do start training he's
like I'll tell them I said ok I think
set up a lunch for me and Rick Berman
and and Gigi so they do and gene says so
you want to do Star Trek I said yeah you
don't understand this was a huge part of
my life this is a huge part of my life
because as a kid who loves science
fiction it wasn't until lieutenant Uhura
did I realize that I was in the future
and you were allowed in the future he
said what do you mean I sent Jamie if
you look at science fiction movies that
predate saw Star Trek there are no
people of color anywhere he was like I
don't think I knew that I said well you
know now so I would like to uphold that
tradition because we know that we're in
the future edition set up by Buitoni
lieutenant Uhura that there is someone
else I've come now you got levar so my
god you might put two of us on ownership
and I know that's probably unusual but
I'd love to do it he said alright so he
created diamond I may be the last
creature he created Wow
that is awesome